[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce
troisième numéro de si on parlait sport
spécial JO aujourd'hui coûte projecteur
sur les sportifs et les JO de 2024 la
compétition sera organisée du 26 juillet
au 11 août et les Jeux paralympiques
sont programmés du 28 août au 8
septembre pour parler de cette
thématique nous avons avec nous sur ce
plateau à des sportifs présentation en
musique de cette magnifique dream team
on commence à ma droite musique c'est un
cavalier de niveau international âgé de
24 ans il a été champion d'Europe de
concours complet par équipe et
individuelle a été champion de France et
son objectif c'est d'être au château de
Versailles aux Jeux olympiques de 2024
il est en très grande forme aujourd'hui
Victor l'évêque qui est avec nous
pendant une heure bonjour Michael ça va
comment allez-vous au Victor très bien
très bien les JO qu'est-ce que ça
signifie
c'est vraiment mon rêve ultime j'essaye
d'en faire un objectif au fur et à
mesure là ça s'approche à grand pas
Paris 2024 voilà on y est pas encore il
reste beaucoup d'étapes mais c'est ce
qui nous motive tous les jours Nicolas
Touzin j'ai vu a remporter l'or par
équipe en concours complet en 2004 à 24
ans à Athènes sur un exemple ouais
Nicolas c'est vous aurez 25 ans du coup
26 ans 26 ans l'année prochaine bon
après voilà moi je pratique un sport ou
finalement c'est peut-être plus un sport
d'expérience par rapport à d'autres
sports voilà il y a pas trop de limite
d'âge donc voilà si je suis champion
olympique à 26 ans ce serait
exceptionnel si je suis à 40 ans ce sera
tout autant et oui Nicolas Touzin c'est
un des voilà quelqu'un qui me fait rêver
qui m'inspire beaucoup un exemple de
notre discipline c'est sûr on continue
notre tour de table à gauche musique
elle a commencé le tennis de table à
l'âge de 12 ans à nous bien tout droit
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux à l'édition
chez licenciée chez skipping à la
participat des événements Skype Skippy
je sais pas je sais pas comment on dit
elle a participé à des événements
mondiaux à les 9e mondial si je me
trompe pas elle devrait réussir des
grandes performances au jeu
paralympiques de 2024 Lucie au Thiers
nous fait le honneur venir sur cette
émission comment allez-vous ici ça va
super
pareil les Jeux paralympiques c'est vous
y pensez
ce sera mes premiers jeux et les faire à
Paris ce sera incroyable et vous serez
dans quelle catégorie
moi je suis engagée en double mixte et
en simple en classe ensuite alors
handisport c'est un peu particulier
parce qu'il y a différentes classes
d'handicap selon le degré d'antia le
degré d'handicap qu'on a un 5 je crois
que c'est en fauteuil c'est ça et après
au-delà si vous êtes debout
et ça va vous êtes motivés
je pense qu'il y aura pas de problème on
repasse de l'autre
côté musique c'est une morue
d'équitation c'est une cavalière
internationale de 22 ans à nous vient
tout droit de Maison-Laffitte à 13 ans
avec sacré championne de France minime
en concours complet elle a été double
médaillée d'or au Championnat d'Europe
junior à nous Canteloup le fait
l'honneur de venir sur ce plateau
bonjour Anouk comment allez-vous ça va
très bien merci alors les Jeux
Olympiques pour vous c'est un rêve
j'imagine depuis toute petite
athlète voilà après comme disait Victor
c'est un sport qu'on a la chance de
pratiquer longtemps donc si c'est pas
Paris ce sera Los Angeles ce sera
l'objectif et dans tous les cas ouais
c'est un rêve et c'est ce qui nous
motive tous les jours il y a une team
équitation si je comprends bien sur sur
la droite du plateau alors on termine de
l'autre côté musique c'est un pistard de
l'équipe de France et les licenciés au
WC le skyting vous serez il a 22 ans il
a déjà participé aux Jeux Olympiques
c'était à Tokyo il a été médaillé de
bronze individuel avec en par équipe
avec Sébastien Vigier Ryan allez il a
les crocs pour les Jeux Olympiques de
2024 Florian grimbaud est avec nous
pendant une heure bonjour comment
allez-vous Florian ça va super plaisir
de partager ça avec vous et parler sport
du coup les Jeux olympiques de 2024 se
seront vus 2e Jeux Olympiques où vous
voulez faire mieux j'imagine évidemment
une fois qu'on a goûté à cette médaille
olympique qui n'est pas de la bonne
couleur encore on a envie de faire mieux
et ça donne les crocs pour la suite vous
imaginez déjà d'envirodontes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors pour
avoir vécu dans le public les
championnats du monde qui ont eu à 50
ans en Yvelines c'était fou avec le
public français on a vu une consécration
de notamment Mathilde gros et c'était
beau donc je me dis chose même pas
imaginer comment ça va être lors des
Jeux de Paris alors on va commencer par
l'actualité des jeux olympiques les
organisateurs ont présenté ce mercredi 8
février l'identité visuelle de chaque
discipline avec les différents
pictogrammes et les couleurs dominantes
de la compétition le rose le bleu le
violet et l'or sur la couleur qui
habilleront les sites les villes et les
partenaires en 2024 les 10000 vont
accueillir le cyclisme surpiste le BMX
Race le VTT le golf équitation le
marathon le pentathlon moderne le
cyclisme sur route des disciplines qui
ont un pictogramme très épuré alors
votre avis sur ces pictogrammes qu'on
voit justement à l'écran que ce que vous
en pensez on valide ou pas
c'est assez minimaliste je pense que
voilà ça reflète bien le sport il y a
pas de furetures je pense que j'ai
réussi Paris réussi
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ou vous
avez pu voir un petit peu le vôtre du
coup sur le site
vous en pensez simple efficace
facilement reconnaissable et je pense
c'est aussi dans l'esprit l'esprit des
jeux c'est à dire universel donc non
c'est top
de mettre des petits personnages qui
font la discipline olympique ça change
un petit peu
c'est sympa de voir autre chose mais à
la fois c'est assez clair donc
ouais c'est efficace les couleurs
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez le rose le
bleu le violet l'or qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez aussi des thématiques qui vont
être autour de l'événement par exemple
au Vélodrome et il y aura du violet un
petit peu de partout qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez bah ça reste dans la chartre
qu'ils ont déjà annoncé un petit peu
avant que les différents enfin les
différentes opérations qu'ils ont faites
donc ça va vraiment dans cette lignée là
moi j'aime bien et la piste d'athlétisme
je sais pas si vous l'avez vu du Stade
de France sera bon on va la voir à
l'instant violette comme ça qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez de cette piste ça
change un petit peu des pistes
d'athlétisme qu'on voit d'habitude
Victor ouais ça change un peu maintenant
je pense que voilà la piste violette
voilà ils ont dû il doit y avoir des
bonnes raisons à ça j'imagine que ça
doit faire plaisir plus grand nombre en
tout cas par rapport au pictogrammes il
y a un peu de toutes les couleurs voilà
je pense que ça vous
de créer une identité visuelle pour
chaque Jeux Olympiques je suis
généralement c'était le rouge je crois
que pour le long c'était le rouge par
exemple qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous Florian on crée ça fait partie
est-ce que ça va vous perturber ou
justement vous en fichez c'est ça pas
plus que ça parce que on fait pas
forcément à cet environnement là mais
c'est vrai que quand je repense à Rio ça
fait penser au jaune et quand je repense
à Londres rouge donc c'est vrai que ça
identifie ça permet d'identifier le jeu
au pays
en compétition on regarde pas du tout ça
on est d'accord non c'est pour le public
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
parlerons de la pression du public
français pendant ces jeux olympiques de
2024 on va également parler des sites
olympiques yvinois mais avant de parler
de ces thématiques on va parler de la
préparation des sportifs pour cet
événement
[Musique]
alors on va parler dans cette thématique
de la préparation des sportifs pour ces
JO de 2024 comment vous allez vous
préparer comment ces sportifs vont se
préparer alors je vais à chaque fois
donner une question sur la thématique et
ensuite on va la développer ensemble
alors la question sur cette thématique
les JO de 2024 se préparent-ils
différemment d'un événement classique
oui ou non vous votez oui c'est vert
rouge c'est non oui pour vous Florian et
non pour vous Victor bon on fait un
petit duel entre vous Florian et Victor
alors Florian vous êtes un peu le seul
contre tous vous allez vous allez
commencer on a déjà vécu oui c'est
peut-être pour ça pour moi ouais c'est
un peu cette idée où les Jeux Olympiques
restent une compétition à part c'est
vrai qu'on voit beaucoup de personnes
qui enfin comment expliquer ça en
prendre l'exemple de Romain canon du
coup en escrime au final moi j'avais pas
trop suivi sa saison et pour moi c'était
pas lui que j'avais en tête et pourtant
c'était des mecs comme ça qui sortent
donc c'est une compétition d'un jour
tout peut arriver même avant par rapport
aux sélections je reprends mon cas ou au
final je suis arrivé à 7h sur cette
sélection olympique
la pression ce n'est pas la même que ce
soit pour les athlètes ou l'encadrement
donc
en repensant à Tokyo je pense qu'on
n'est pas encore prêt pour les jeux de
Paris ça va être tellement grandiose
quand on voit le peu d'activation enfin
rien qu'en voyant le peu d'activation
qu'ils ont fait l'engouement le public
je pense que toute cette pression faut
la travailler et c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas forcément conscience en
tant qu'athlète parce que pour nous on
nous demande en l'occurrence d'appui que
sur les pédales on me demande pas autre
chose mais toutes ces choses là c'est
des choses à préparer parce que ça va
être autre chose une autre compétition
c'est à part attention il a mis la barre
c'est très enrichissant d'autant plus
que voilà moi j'ai jamais vécu de jeux
olympiques Florian oui et en plus avec
succès bah moi justement c'est pour
toutes les raisons que que tu évoquais
évidemment qu'on entend toujours que les
jeux c'est une compétition à part on n'a
pas de pareil parce que il y a beaucoup
de pression beaucoup plus de
médiatisation etc mais en tout cas pour
mon cas après chacun je pense à sa
manière de se préparer je pense que
justement en essayant de ne rien changer
finalement à sa préparation en restant
focalisé en restant dans sa bulle bah
tête ce qui peut nous permettre de
rester concentré justement pas nous
disperser avec tous ces à-côtés là donc
si j'ai la chance de participer aux jeux
de paris 2024 bah moi j'essaierai de
garder on va dire mon protocole ma
méthode d'entraînement de concentration
et c'est de ne rien changer puisque si
j'y suis a priori c'est que ça aura
marché tout au long de l'année donc qui
vous a convaincu
elle est obligée c'est la team
équitation qui parle pourquoi je suis
d'accord si la recette elle a marché
pour la sélection faut rien changer ça
veut dire que ça a marché pour les
échanges d'avant donc il faut rester
dans cette rigueur là en plus nous on
fait un sport assez particulier où il y
a l'animal et l'art de rien il a besoin
de repère aussi lui dans l'échauffement
donc il faut garder une routine pour que
ce soit rassurant pour tout le monde et
pas désorganisé les choses avant une
échéance comme ça Lucie donc vous êtes
plus aussi avec Victor et Yannick oui
parce que enfin alors au tennis de table
on peut jouer on peut faire des masques
tout le temps vraiment tout le temps moi
je suis dit dans deux fédérations je
suis en valide et en handisport et du
coup je j'ai tout le temps des
compétitions et c'est sûr que les jeux
c'est un objectif mais il y a après les
jeux où je ferai quand même des couper
je continuerai le tennis de table et les
compétitions et il y a toute la saison
bah cette année ou même l'année dernière
ou bah on fait des compétitions et où on
je suis tout le temps
en compétition et en
les jeux c'est une grosse confusion mais
ce sera pas
finalement non
si on réussit toute l'année
toutes les conditions de l'année en soit
j'irai au jeu et qu'est-ce qui change
finalement d'une compétition classique
c'est l'ampleur de l'événement ou parce
que finalement comme vous disiez à
l'instant Lucie un match de tennis de
table c'est un match de tennis de table
dans ces routines et à être dans son
dans sa bulle pour pouvoir
pas forcément être en pression le jour
de la compétition Florian
moi je reste en fait sur mon avis
quand on sait au jeu il y a 1% des
personnes qui participent au jeu qui
sont médaillés donc
enfin après dans notre sport les Jeux
Olympiques ont une telle importance
c'est vraiment la course et d'autant
plus les jeux de Paris je pense que pour
le sport français
il y a pas mieux dans le sens où moi mon
objectif de carrière ça a été avant
quand jouer être dans le haut niveau
c'était pas Tokyo c'est ce sont les jeux
de paris moi ma carrière
c'est vers là que je veux tendre après
il y aura Los Angeles évidemment ou des
choses comme ça mais les jeux français
non c'est à nous c'est chez nous on est
obligé on doit faire oui le fait que ça
soit en France ça change beaucoup de
choses j'imagine à nuque ouais après
c'est stimulant c'est une motivation
supplémentaire on a la chance à 8h
d'avoir fait un championnat d'Europe à
domicile à Fontainebleau on avait
remporté l'or et c'est vrai que c'est un
goût particulier quand on a notre
famille nos amis et le public français
avec nous quoi donc c'est je pense que
c'est une pression mais en même temps
c'est une envie encore plus de bien
faire pour eux est-ce qu'on a pas envie
peut-être dans la préparation de trop en
faire quand c'est à domicile justement
est-ce qu'on a pas envie de trop en
faire de peut-être mettre des surcharges
je sais pas de travail en plus peut-être
c'est je pense qu'il faut garder la même
préparation parce qu'après sinon on peut
risquer de blesser si on va trop fort
dans l'entraînement donc là dessus je
pense qu'il faut garder à notre
sang-froid on va dire être resté lucide
et
faire pas changer de cap quoi est-ce que
vous connaissez peut-être votre
programme déjà pour pour les prochains
mois ou pas Victor parce que vous les
connaissez alors je pense que pour la
plupart des sports en tout cas dans dans
le nôtre nous on se qualifie en fait aux
Jeux Olympiques l'année qui précède les
jeunes donc cette année de qualification
donc c'est une année vraiment
extrêmement importante et ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est qu'il y a bien
deux choses distinctes en tout cas nous
en équitation concours complet il y a
d'un côté la qualification et de l'autre
la sélection donc en 2023 chaque couple
on raisonne toujours en termes de couple
cavalier cheval puisqu'on peut pas nous
dissocier en fait c'est la machine à
sport chaque couple devra se qualifier
selon des certains niveaux établis par
la Fédération Équestre Internationale
donc peu importe les pays au cours de
cette année donc il y a une vraie année
un vrai enjeu pour nous et l'année de
2024 du coup à quelques mois des Jeux
Olympiques le sélectionneur de l'équipe
de France de concours complet choisira
d'après lui quelles sont les meilleurs
couples à même de représenter la France
vous pouvez pas prendre le cheval de
quelqu'un
des Jeux Olympiques c'est le très très
haut niveau c'est le summum on a la
chance de faire un sport qui est présent
aux Jeux Olympiques donc évidemment
c'est des projets comme le disait tout à
l'heure Florian c'est voilà des projets
de vie dans le sens où bomba nous voilà
on partage cette aventure avec un être
un être vivant un cheval on peut pas
prendre un cheval et deux mois après
dire je vais aller aux Jeux Olympiques
voilà c'est des chevaux qu'on monte
qu'on entraîne avec qui on se prépare de
longs longs mois avant Florian est-ce
que vous connaissez un petit peu votre
programme ou pas d'ici 2024 alors
évidemment comme une phase de
qualification en fait je pense que tous
les autres sports qui est du coup cette
année et puis l'année d'après on rentre
dans la préparation et aussi la
sélection ce qu'on a déjà un groupe à
faire un peu préfet au sein de notre
structure et du coup au sein de ce
groupe il sera déterminé normalement si
j'ai pas de bêtises au mois de janvier
la composition complète pour les jeux
qui sont reliés au mois d'août ici
on a on n'a pas encore les critères de
sélection pour participer au Jeu de
Paris
alors que c'est l'année prochaine on
commence l'année de qualification
et
après on a beaucoup de compétitions dans
l'année du coup en fait en fonction de
des matchs gagné les matchs perdus bah
on va faire plus ou moins de
compétitions donc nous ça peut quand
même on va dire beaucoup varier et après
au niveau des derniers mois ce que vous
savez comment vous allez peut-être
articuler votre préparation ou pas du
tout c'est trop long
pour le moment c'est un peu vague et
est-ce que c'est le moment peut-être de
tester aussi des nouvelles choses
éventuellement je sais pas des
programmes un peu spécifiques ou pas je
sais pas après si c'est non pas du tout
en fait je pense que
mine de rien quand on se prépare une
échéance comme ça généralement on a un
plan qui est assez établi je pense qu'on
connaît son cheval on connaît voilà les
épreuves qu'on a besoin de faire mais
peut-être la particularité est vraiment
tout l'enjeu c'est que souvent on pense
sélection moi mon rêve c'est de faire
les Jeux Olympiques pour être champion
olympique évidemment médaille c'est
super mais je veux dire mon rêve c'est
pas d'aller aux Jeux olympiques et là il
y a une nuance dans le sens où quand
aujourd'hui j'ai réfléchi et je projette
ma saison avec ce rêve là en tête
évidemment bah je me projette en me
disant voilà quels sont les ingrédients
qu'il faut que je mette en place comment
il faut que je m'entraîne pour être au
top du top de ma forme avec mon cheval
au mois de fin durant l'été 2024 mais
c'est pas de me dire bah voilà mon
objectif c'est de me sélectionner et
puis après on verra bien parce que voilà
une saison ça se construit ça se prépare
je pense c'est le cas dans tous les
sports il y a des compétitions ou bah
qui sont là peut-être en début de saison
pour se remettre en forme il y a des
saisons qui sont là peut-être pour faire
des tests et essayer d'aller chercher
des petits réglages de ces des
compétitions on va aller peut-être se
mettre un peu dans le rouge voir un peu
la limite ce qu'on peut aller des
compétitions où là on sait qu'on va
essayer d'appliquer exactement le plan
qu'on qu'on a en tête et voir si ça
marche donc voilà je pense qu'une saison
ça se construit une saison c'est long et
il faut toujours garder en tête voilà
fraîcheur mental physique pour pour se
préparer pour les chances est-ce que
vous préparez aussi mentalement aussi
pour ce type d'événement aussi qui va
avoir énormément de pression depuis tout
à l'heure
pour préparer mentalement je sais pas ce
que vous avez des coachs mentaux est-ce
que vos entraîneurs vous aident
peut-être à se préparer sur ce domaine
là ou pas
je pense c'est
on va dire 80% de la performance lors
des jeux dans la tête parce que tout
peut glisser si facilement une petite
erreur il faut rester concentré donc
ouais ça se travaille en fait tout au
long de l'année donc avec des
traitementsales avec un entourage en
fait c'est juste la structure dans
laquelle on est avec les gens à qui on
évolue autour de nous qui nous permet
justement en fait de faire tampon avec
cette pression et d'arriver lors des
Jeux sereins et je pense que c'est
surtout ça c'est arrivé serein sur sur
ces jeux là savoir pourquoi on est là en
fait et pas se poser la question sur sur
la ligne en disant mais qu'est-ce que je
fais là en fait parce que là c'est le
coup à tout louper donc ouais c'est
c'est quand même très important cet
aspect mental préparation mentale ou pas
spécialement la préparation mentale au
tennis de table vu que c'est un sport de
duel elle est très importante parce que
ça joue sur
des fois ça joue sur de la chance un peu
de tout on peut avoir un point de chance
on peut avoir une balle où on n'est pas
concentré et on loupe on loupe alors que
Ben où on loupe un service et du coup on
perd le match enfin c'est le tennis de
table ça peut aller très vite aussi donc
il s'agit bien sûr comme sur tous les
sports sur des détails
mais l'aspect mental est très très
important au tennis de table des fois ça
joue sur sur ça
en équitation est-ce que ce que vous en
parlez et du coup vous êtes deux
Mandal à mon cheval encore moi j'en ai
pas du tout non non
je pose la question
moi j'en ai fait pendant un ou deux ans
et après j'ai arrêté parce que parce
qu'en fait je me suis mis dans une
routine avec voilà un réglage enfin avec
un coach qui me rassure voilà on a on a
mis nos réglages en place après je j'en
avais je sentais que j'en avais plus
forcément besoin mais en tout cas
pendant les deux années où j'ai
sollicité un coach mental ouais ça m'a
bien aidé pour gérer la pression
depuis longtemps j'ai quelqu'un voilà
avec qui je je partage alors après c'est
vrai que dans le je suis pas dans la
fonction de préparateur mental je pense
qu'on peut mettre plein de choses ça
peut être quelqu'un ça peut être aussi
quelqu'un de ton entourage finalement
qui joue un peu ce rôle là moi j'ai
quelqu'un d'extérieur au final je pense
que j'ai toujours assez bien réussi à
gérer la pression par contre moi c'était
important d'avoir quelqu'un à qui je
pouvais me confier donc était vraiment
complètement extérieur à mon système
c'est à dire qu'il était ni entraîneur
ni propriétaire de cheval enfin voilà
c'était quelqu'un à qui je pouvais
vraiment tout dire c'était pas non plus
quelqu'un demande de ma famille moi
j'avais besoin d'avoir voilà un peu
cette soupape aujourd'hui c'est
quelqu'un voilà avec qui j'entretiens de
très bonne relation qui continue à me
suivre voilà c'est une personne avec qui
je sais que à tout moment je peux lui
passer un coup de fil le voir et me
vider de toute chose on va passer
maintenant notre deuxième thématique on
va parler de la pression du public
fonction on a déjà commencé à l'évoquer
un petit peu avant sur les 13 millions
de tickets qui sont mis en vente dont 10
pour les Jeux Olympiques et trois pour
les paralympiques on imagine déjà les
gradins en plein de drapeau français on
imagine aussi les une des français qui
vont faire monter la pression avant
l'événement la question sur cette
deuxième thématique doit-on se mettre
dans sa bulle pour
ça continue
alors faire un petit duel aller avec
nous qui allez si on fait à nous qui
Florian pour changer un petit peu et
Victor pourra ensuite arbitrer même si
je pense qu'il va vite en faveur Danube
peut-être alors Anouk
je suis désolée mais
oui pour moi on doit se mettre dans sa
bulle on doit rien changer on doit faire
ce qui ce qui marche pour les épreuves
d'avance on est là c'est pas pour rien
et voilà faut essayer de garder le cap à
un maximum sans justement se laisser
inhiber par la pression du public ça
doit être une motivation supplémentaire
mais ça doit pas voilà nous on doit
rester focus sur ce qu'on sait faire et
voilà je pense que est-ce que vous avez
parlé aux médias je sais pas par exemple
moi j'ai pas trop l'expérience alors je
pense qu'il a plus d'arguments que moi
vu qu'il a déjà participé à une Olympia
mais voilà
je suis pas trop légitime pour parler de
ça vu que j'ai pas j'ai pas l'expérience
encore Florian alors moi je pense qu'il
faut pas s'enfermer dans sa bulle parce
que tout simplement les jeux c'est
universel c'est le moment de pouvoir
faire rêver des taux de personnes moi
c'est ce qui m'a amené en fait à faire
mon sport tout simplement en regardant
les jeux en voyant c'est bête mais un
autre blague faire du vélo chose que
l'avez jamais vu en lisant ses
interviews moi ça m'a motivé et ça m'a
en fait permis
de aujourd'hui être à sa place et il
m'entraîne aujourd'hui donc je suis
content donc pour moi c'est quand même
important parce que c'est tellement
universel ça fait rêver tellement de
monde que en fait on doit être juste
pour drapeau de ces valeurs là donc
après je dis pas non plus
d'aller de partout se vendre et tout ça
mais quand même garder un bon
relationnel justement aussi avec les
médias parce que il suffit d'avoir une
compétition
un peu tumultueuse avant et il vous
enterre et derrière on dit qu'on prend
du recul mais bon quand il y a un
article qui sort on est tous les
premiers à les lire donc quand même
garder des bonnes relations justement
avec les médias et pas justement faire
l'inverse l'inaccessible et je suis dans
ma bulle et m'embêtait pas enfin c'est
mon avis
non je pense que vous êtes plus
aujourd'hui
c'est tout je pense tout l'enjeu pour
pour un grand champion c'est de savoir
justement se connaître se gérer il y a
des moments où je pense qu'on a besoin
de se concentrer justement pas trop à
être distrait par tous ces
sollicitations là puisque même si on est
là pour promouvoir les valeurs du sport
et tout on est aussi là pour essayer de
ramener les plus belles médailles pour
la France et évidemment des moments où
on doit être disponible pour répondre
aux différentes sollicitations à faire
rêver les gens promouvoir les valeurs de
nos disciplines et notre sport donc
voilà c'est tout le challenge et je
pense que la force une des grandes
forces de l'équipe de France de point de
vue très général je pense justement ce
partage d'expérience entre tous les
athlètes qui faisons tous fait rêver
toute discipline confondues très
expérimentée et aussi peut-être la jeune
génération qu'on incarne aussi voilà moi
j'ai la chance de connaître quelques
sportifs je discute souvent avec eux à
des jeux olympiques c'est des gens qui
me font rêver d'avoir un peu ce recul et
se partage d'expérience ça peut aussi
nous aider à nous préparer au mieux
je trouve que le jeu paralympiques c'est
un moment unique mais il faut rester vu
qu'on est athlète faut rester quand même
dans un esprit de compétition même s'il
y a des moments où il va falloir parler
aux médias il va falloir faire des
choses qu'on ne fait pas
dans toutes les autres compétitions mais
voilà faut garder un cap et
tout en voulant faire rêver d'autres
jeunes qui veulent peut-être se lancer
aussi dans le sport et qui n'ose pas ou
voilà
[Musique]
peut-être les jeunes aussi pour les
pousser à devenir peut-être comme vous
du coup dans l'équitation éventuellement
est-ce que vous serez de ce type de
sportif
moi d'un point de vue personnel je suis
quelqu'un de plutôt assez réservé en
tout cas je ne pense pas être le plus
grand chômage
à cheval par contre évidemment je pense
que voilà les Jeux Olympiques c'est
l'événement planétaire ultime tous les
sports n'ont pas la chance d'être
présent aux Jeux Olympiques le concours
complet en fait partie donc il faut
aussi savourer cette chance et voilà si
on veut que ce sport perdure et continue
à y rester puisqu'il y a plein de
nouveaux sports émergents qui poussent
aussi qui tape à la porte c'est
important voilà de jouer le jeu bien sûr
on a cette casquette d'athlète mais on a
aussi l'autre casquette et voilà c'est
important de répondre aux stations
puisque c'est une chance que des gens
s'intéressent à nous alors après je
pense que voilà nous l'équitation ça
reste un sport assez confidentiel ce
sera un enjeu à Paris parce qu'on n'a
pas l'habitude de faire des comp avec
autant de publics et annoncé et signé
d'autographes ça nous arrive assez
rarement mais ça peut arriver mais voilà
il faut un petit peu se préparer à ça
après je pense qu'il y a aussi on a
aussi un devoir dans notre communication
c'est voilà notre manière de répondre
mais aussi dans ce qu'on diffuse et ce
qu'on véhicule comme image voilà un
devoir de pédagogie de faire valoir les
belles valeurs de notre sport justement
pour que j'espère après ces jeux là il y
a des images très fortes au château de
Versailles de complicité etc et de
respect entre le chaos et le cheval pour
que cette magnifique discipline perdure
vous voyez comment
on a la chance d'être aux Jeux
Olympiques c'est une chance énorme et on
se doit de
d'aller répondre à présent journaliste
d'aller rencontrer les gens faire rêver
les jeunes c'est voilà on c'est pas une
obligation mais mais c'est aussi notre
rôle
que vous êtes plutôt ouvert sur votre
public par rapport au public et en fait
ce que j'ai compris après Tokyo c'est
que le fait d'avoir une médaille peu
importe la couleur au final c'est une
médaille de bronze c'est pas la plus
belle des médailles
c'est pas gagné enfin voilà mais ça
reste une médaille olympique et dans les
dans les yeux des gens c'est c'est un
tel pouvoir que en fait on se doit de
partager ce truc je vais raconter une
anecdote ma médaille elle commence à
patiner beaucoup et un jour je suis allé
sur Paris pour demander justement s'il y
a quelque chose à faire et tout et le
mec qui me regarde il me dit mais non
c'est l'histoire de la médaille si toi
tu veux la partager ma partage là elle
en gardera les traces et j'ai trouvé ça
fort parce que moi c'est mon faire
valoir c'est de partager donc
je suis là pour partager en fait tout
simplement j'aurais rêvé quand un gamin
que quelqu'un le fasse donc je le ferai
Lucie je pense qu'il y a des il y aura
des moments où on devra avoir la cascade
d'athlète et donc du coup pas forcément
s'occuper du public ou pas forcément
occuper des médias et il y aura des
moments où on pourra justement s'en
occuper et promouvoir le sport français
et le handisport donc vous souriez un
petit peu sur les deux en fait si je
comprends bien un petit peu dans votre
bulle mais également un peu ouverte sur
l'extérieur et qu'est-ce qu'il faut
craindre le plus à votre avis le public
ou les médias finalement sur ce type
d'événement aucun des deux aucun des
deux
parce que ça peut ça peut piquer et ça
peut faire mal et sur des petits détails
alors qu'on est serein même si on se met
dans sa bulle on est quand même au
courant de tout on est connecté tout le
monde un téléphone une notification
ou pas pendant la compétition est-ce que
mais quand on est sur le site olympique
on regarde quand même ce qui se passe
justement on se nourrit de ce qui se
passe de voir des mecs avec des
médailles sans sa motive donc
toujours on ne peut pas brancher en fait
en quelque sorte être hermétique à tout
ça pour moi vaut mieux en fait
travailler
comment s'approprier ça que de le
rejeter et justement aller dans le mur
jusqu'au jour où on fête on se rencontre
il y a un article et là on s'écrase à
votre avis un athlète qui dit je suis
dans ma bulle j'ai rien vu j'ai rien
entendu
vous y croyez pas j'ai du mal à y croire
quand même parce que c'est l'intoxiqué
on est connecté on essaie de génération
là donc
on est obligé de tout savoir et qu'est
ce que vous aimeriez dire aux
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent là en
ce moment et qui vous regarderont
peut-être sur les prochains jeux
olympiques qu'est-ce que vous aimerez
leur dire vous en tant que sportif
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire au public
français tout simplement bah beaucoup
nous encourager mais pas trop qu'on a le
cheval maintenant
bah voilà moi j'ai jamais vécu un
événement de cette ampleur mais
évidemment qu'il faut qu'il y ait de
l'émotion qu'il faut qu'il y ait du
partage peu importe au final bah on
espère tous que des moments de joie il y
aura pas que ça il y aura je pense
toutes les émotions qu'on vivra donc je
pense que c'est une aventure collective
voilà le sport c'est quelque chose qui
fait d'air donc il faut que chacun le
vive et surtout que cette aventure et
ses émotions soient partagées peu
importe qu'on soit athlète ou
spectateurs
les jeux de Paris ça arrivera qu'une
fois donc
faut en profiter non mais faut en
profiter faut venir le supporter les
athlètes et
c'est comme ça que aussi il y a des
athlètes qui vont réussir à en se
soutenant en
justement
se soutenir enfin justement voyons qu'il
y a des athlètes que tout le monde se
soutienne ça sera bien Florian vous avez
un petit message à leur adressé moi je
dirais regardez tous les sports
découvrez vibrer je pense surtout vibrer
parce que ça transmet tellement
d'émotions que on est obligé de tout
partager et même le public français et
même les Français ne sont pas
hermétiques à ça donc juste adoré c'est
la fête du sport c'est en France tous
les Français sont là pour nous on est là
pour eux donc peut-être juste aussi de
rajouter que on a la chance à Paris
d'avoir de nouveaux sports notamment le
break qui va émerger je pense que voilà
c'est sur des événements comme les jeux
qui sont largement diffusés à la télé
qu'on peut donner envie à des à des
jeunes de pratiquer différents sports
que ce soit l'équitation le breakdance
enfin un peu importe et ne pas oublier
aussi les Jeux paralympiques breakdance
d'ailleurs il y a eu beaucoup de
compétitions dans les emails ces
derniers mois il y en a une à
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse dernièrement
donc on voit que ça prend l'ampleur
alors qu'on en parlait pas forcément il
y a quelques mois donc voilà c'est aussi
ça les Jeux Olympiques alors on va
maintenant parler des sites olympiques
qui viennois qui vont accueillir les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
des sites que vous allez vous sportif
tester dans quelques mois je vais faire
un petit tour d'horizon des sites
olympiques les Yvelines vont accueillir
le cyclisme sur piste et le parasyclisme
sur piste au vélo de national de 50 ans
en Yvelines le BMX Race sera juste à
côté sur le Stadium de BMX de 50 ans en
Yvelines le VTT sera sur la colline
Delancourt le golf au Golf National de
50 ans en Yvelines l'équitation sera sur
le magnifique site du château de
Versailles le marathon passera par
Versailles et Viroflay le pentathlon
moderne sera le château de Versailles
également le cyclisme sur route devrait
passer par la vallée de Chevreuse et
sûrement 50 ans en Yvelines et
Versailles la question sur cette
thématique est-ce que le site TV noir
vous séduisent oui ou non pas voir s'il
y a un débat je pense je ne pense pas
mais on ne sait pas donc est-ce que ça
vous séduit tout simplement voilà
j'imagine bien que je voudrais pas trop
de débats alors oui qu'est-ce qui vous
plaît on va parler peut-être du château
de Versailles pour pour l'équitation
qu'est-ce qui vous plaît dans dans ce
château de Versailles à nous peut-être
difficile de dire qu'on est pas content
de faire les JO là-bas on est très
chanceux et c'est un site extraordinaire
de par son histoire les chevaux à
Versailles enfin ça va faire des images
magnifiques et et comme disait Victor
pour pour la médiatisation de notre
sport j'espère qu'on aura de belles
images avec les chevaux à Versailles qui
vont rayonner dans le monde quoi
certains disent que ce sera peut-être
les plus beaux jeux olympiques pour
l'équitation est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord Victor alors j'ai pas la plus
grande culture de ce point de vue là
mais étant vraiment passionné de sport
ouais je suis les jeux depuis que
peut-être j'ai l'âge de suivre et oui je
pense que effectivement en tout cas les
promesses sont immenses et ouais ça
risque de faire quelque chose ce décor
est vraiment magnifique
voilà déjà ça mettre en avant tout le
patrimoine français donc voilà la France
qui est certainement le plus beau pays
du monde et oui avoir une épreuve
olympique dans le parc tu vas tout de
faire ça et pour nous l'équitation c'est
inimaginable et on a beaucoup de chance
puisque voilà ce site a été longtemps
débattu au final Paris 2024 a réussi à
tenir voilà l'événement là-bas donc à
nous d'en profiter oui certains vont
essayer d'attirer l'équitation je crois
la Motte Beuvron
il y a eu plusieurs sites en débat la
mode Beuvron Fontainebleau peut-être
aussi chantilly voilà toujours
l'Île-de-France ou proche Paris mais
ouais c'est une chance inouïe d'avoir
les jeux à Versailles alors pour vous ça
sera pas dans les Yvelines par contre ça
sera du coup du côté de l'Arena par
issue de 4 au Parc des Expositions à la
Porte de Versailles qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez de ce lieu de ce site ça va
être top honnêtement ça va être génial
d'avoir fait de faire une compétition
là-dedans vous connaissez un petit peu
ou pas vous êtes déjà fait des
compétitions là-bas
mais
aussi c'était sympa franchement c'est
chouette et soit aussi ton implique
alors du coup qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez enfin Olympiques qui sont dans
les Yvelines qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez je trouve que les sites qui ont
été choisis ils ont une histoire et que
une culture et du coup par exemple le
château de Versailles quand une
équitation au château de Versailles
c'est que
quand on nous dit à quelqu'un
château de Versailles tout de suite on
pense on pense à la France on pense
à toute l'histoire que ça enferme et
peut-être aussi vous avez pu tester je
crois lors d'une compétition de tennis
de table en mai dernier il y a une
compétition Vélodrome et pareil c'était
grandiose après il y avait pas beaucoup
de public malheureusement mais
j'espère quand même Florian ce vélo de
route on va parler de cette vidéo c'est
c'est difficile de faire mieux quand on
voit les les images des championnats du
monde qui ont lieu en octobre du coup
j'étais dans le public non parce que
vous étiez blessé en octobre
à ce moment-là donc j'ai pas pu du coup
faire les championnats du monde mais
c'est vrai que le vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est une
belle structure même la piste en
elle-même il y en a très peu comme ça
dans le monde si ce n'est enfin quand on
discute avec les autres nations
quel est votre développement préféré le
Paradise 51
sur tous les vendre que j'ai pu faire
pour l'instant c'est vraiment
Saint-Quentin qui est vraiment le top du
top le dessin est tellement beau le bois
il y aura tellement bien que c'est une
piste à chrono
ce vélo Drôme c'est un terme de d'acous
c'est juste le dessin du Vélodrome en
lui-même ou la piste elle est un mètre
plus large que les autres pistes du que
ça fait gagner un peu en hauteur et du
coup sur les sprints de lancement ça
permet en fait d'aller plus vite et
aussi c'est grandiose enfin j'ai pas
critiqué les autres pistes mais quand on
va sur les autres pistes on a
l'impression de retourner sur un circuit
de karting alors que toute l'année on
s'entraîne sur un cercle un circuit de
F1 donc ouais il y a quand même enfin
c'est comme un beau bébé est-ce que vous
en pensez du vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines belle
structure qui a qui a résisté enfin qui
devait être construit pour les Jeux
Olympiques de 2012 à Paris bon ce sont
les Anglais finalement qui l'ont emporté
c'est le seul projet qui a qui a réussi
à à perdurer qui a été le vélodrome
s'est construit en 2015 si mes souvenirs
sont bons qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
de ce mode de national
lors d'un week-end bleu organisé
justement pour
assembler les équipes de France et
c'était la première fois que j'y allais
et c'est vrai que c'est assez
impressionnant mais j'avais jamais allée
et pareil j'ai suivi j'étais pas dans le
public mais j'ai suivi à les
championnats du monde et j'espère
pouvoir être présente pour pour les
soutenir pour Paris
[Musique]
compétition par contre voilà
effectivement je suis pas expert de la
discipline mais ça a l'air d'être une
magnifique structure et je trouve que
notamment au travers de ce championnats
du monde il y a une vraie dynamique une
vraie énergie qui s'est en tout cas avec
cette dégagé pour des gens comme moi qui
sommes complètement extérieur on en a
entendu parler et il y a des images
qu'on circulées et qui nous ont marqué
le sodium de BMX Florian qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez qui est juste à côté du
coup le statut
un petit peu les week-ends
[Musique]
toi aussi pour que ça soit filmé avec
des drones notamment donc c'est ça ouais
normalement ça devrait rester à peu près
comme ça le Stadium à côté c'est vrai
que quand on va voir les entraînements
où j'ai vu quelques coupes du monde qui
sont passés justement par là-bas bah
c'est une super piste même les BMXers
quand on discute avec eux ils sont super
contents de là où ils s'entraîne en fait
donc très content globalement Lucile
vous en pensez quoi ou si vous êtes
passé à côté parce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez pu voir un petit
peu ce Stadium de BMX j'ai vu du coup
quand il y avait la compétition de
tennis de table au Vélodrome on a vu un
peu les pistes de BMX et les gens
s'entraîner là-bas
et franchement ça a l'air impressionnant
et je le ferai j'en ferai pas
je crois qu'ils ont dû refaire la
première la première bosse parce qu'il y
avait trop d'accidents justement sur la
première bosse donc ils ont dû ils ont
dû leur faire la colline d'Élancourt qui
va accueillir les épreuves de VTT en
2024 pareil vous en pensez quoi je me
tourne vers vous parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de cyclisme dans les Yvelines
parce que vous en pensez d'un point de
vue coeur parce que mon club organise
toutes les années
le vaisseau qui organise la revanche
donc ça a quand même un petit aspect
sentimental parce que là où va se
dérouler les jeux c'est là où se déroule
une compète toutes les années entre nous
donc
ultra content j'ai hâte de voir
justement l'infrastructure en elle-même
comment elle va être faite on voit les
images il y a beaucoup de travail sur
cette colline
je précise il y a beaucoup de travail
pour avoir été aux championnats du monde
où j'ai cette année
je pense que le VTT c'est une très belle
discipline
c'est spectaculaire c'est beau donc
s'ils arrivent à retranscrire toutes ces
émotions là qui a été vécue au
championnat du monde objet bah ce sera
tout gagné le VTT qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Victor c'est aussi une belle
compétition pour ces JO de tempête je
connais pas du tout le site je partage
les avis c'est le sport d'Île-de-France
231 mètres je dormirai moins bête ce
soir
le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui a
accueilli la Ryder Cup va accueillir du
coup c'est ces Jeux Olympiques 2020 de
2024 ça sera le premier site au monde à
accueillir à la fois la Ryder Cup qui
est l'équivalent de la Coupe du Monde du
Golfe et les Jeux Olympiques qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez du Golf National
j'y suis déjà allé je connais assez peu
mais j'y suis déjà passé et bah voilà
c'est formidable je pense que ça
démontre aussi toute la stratégie de de
Paris 2024 de se servir de cette
existant je pense que dans la plupart
des sports on est en France des
magnifiques structures puisqu'on a un
pays de sport et voilà ça démontre cette
stratégie et je pense que pour l'avenir
voilà c'est la casquette un peu citoyen
qui parle c'est génial est-ce que les
golfeurs autour de cette table ou pas
le faire vous avez testé ou pas j'y suis
jamais allé sinon tu fais mon premier
essai et alors magnifique
le marathon qui passera par le château
de Versailles là aussi c'est une bonne
idée aussi pareil que vous en pensez
pareil pas loin de l'équitation
complètement bah ça qui est très
représenté aussi au niveau des Jeux
Olympiques je pense que voilà le
département des Yvelines plus largement
l'Île-de-France accueille quand même
évidemment la majorité des sites donc
c'est génial pour tous les gens qu'on la
chance d'habiter à habiter ici voilà le
marathon je pense que c'est top ça
permet de voilà ne pas rester que dans
Paris d'aller aussi un peu à côté je
pense qu'il y a une grande passion
française de la course à pied donc
j'imagine que ça va faire beaucoup de
Florian qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
marathon château de Versailles c'est top
c'est top en plus c'est un marathon pour
tous donc
tous les Français vont pouvoir en fait
justement partager ce que ce que vont
vivre les athlètes donc c'est une
première c'est une première et du coup
c'est quand même emblématique c'est beau
de d'avoir en fait comme tu l'as dit
tout à l'heure les monuments français
tout ce qui fait penser à la France
réuni dans ces jeux quoi il y a beaucoup
de touristes au château de Versailles je
pense qu'il y en aura peut-être un peu
plus après les Jeux Olympiques le
cyclisme sur route qui passera alors on
n'a pas le tracé officiel mais qui
devrait passer par la la vallée de
Chevreuse pareil c'est le berceau on va
dire du cyclisme en Île-de-France La
Valette Chevreuse quelques routes
d'entraînement le week-end c'est vrai
que ça nous arrive assez souvent de
rouler là-bas donc ouais c'est on croise
beaucoup de cyclistes donc c'est propice
justement à une belle épreuve c'est
qu'il se met sur route pareil ça fera
des belles images aussi
je suis allé quelquefois parce que j'ai
ma fac qui est pas très loin
[Musique]
donc j'imagine que apparemment il y aura
du niveau voilà il y aura un vrai défi
un vrai défi sportif là-bas en tout cas
vous l'aurez compris on est très gâté
dans les emails au niveau des épreuves
on va maintenant aborder notre dernière
thématique on va parler de l'après Jeux
Olympiques pour les sportifs on sait
cette compétition va être suivie par
énormément de monde tous les Français
devraient regarder au moins une épreuve
de l'événement la question sur cette
thématique les JO de 2024 vont-ils
développer le sport en France oui ou non
ou voter c'est le moment
comme on le dit depuis tout à l'heure ça
fait rêver les gens on espère que ça va
inciter les jeunes à se mettre au sport
à découvrir d'autres sports donc ça peut
que être stimulant de ce point là
je partage complètement ce que nous
venait de dire je pense qu'on a tous
commencé le sport parce qu'on a vu un
moment une compète un champion un
journal qui nous a donné envie d'être
comme cette personne là ou de pratiquer
ce sport là donc les Jeux Olympiques
étant l'événement sportif par excellence
évidemment que je pense ça va créer
beaucoup de vocations et puis je trouve
aussi que voilà le Comité olympique se
mobilise et essaye de voilà mettre en
place des actions et générations 2024 il
y a le sport pour tous donc voilà le but
c'est que le sport prenne une place
encore un peu plus importante en France
et voilà face évoluer un peu la société
vous sentez Florian ou pas un effet Jo
ou pas ouais complètement mais que ce
soit le lendemain des Jeux de Tokyo ou
on a eu une arrivée sur le trocadéro
enfin un petit désactivation qui ont été
faites par Paris 2024 et justement ça a
montré l'envie et
ça projette en fait ce que va être les
jeux de paris donc on l'a senti dès
qu'on a mis un pied à terre en France en
fait et ça fait que augmenter
le projet vraiment de parler 2024 ça a
été fait juste après les Jeux de Tokyo
aussi on a vraiment senti un changement
après je Tokyo pour parler du 24 on a eu
beaucoup plus de il y a eu beaucoup plus
événements beaucoup plus de
sensibilisation ne serait-ce que par
rapport au sport ou handisport
et je le sens encore enfin moi
personnellement je le sens encore plus
en 2023 lors de l'année de qualification
et autour de cet homme est-ce que vous
êtes déjà allé voir peut-être
éventuellement des élèves des enfants
peut-être pour leur parler des Jeux
olympiques ou pas encore
nous lors de la première compétition
internationale qui s'est déroulée
dans mon club au gymnase des pyramides
de Voisins-le-Bretonneux il y a eu des
enfants qui sont venus mais en fait de
base vous n'avez pas payé le gymnase
parce que bah en fait il y avait une
les écoles venaient pour découvrir le
tennis de table et en plus le tennis de
table handisport et après on a fait tout
le tour des écoles pour présenter ce que
c'était que le tennis de table ce que
c'était que le sport de haut niveau ce
que c'était que handisport toutes ces
thématiques là on a pu en parler aux
enfants et les sensibiliser aussi
à tout ça il y a eu des études qui ont
été faites après les Jeux Olympiques de
Londres 92% les enseignants dans les
écoles ont déclaré que les jeux avaient
été une source d'inspiration pour leurs
élèves au Royaume-Uni plus de 41 000
enfants se sont mis au sport et ont
atteint les niveaux d'activité physique
recommandé ça peut être pareil à Paris à
votre avis Florian ce sera mieux ce sera
mieux je pense c'est l'ambition qu'ils
ont aussi le sport pour tous et
justement en fait amener des vocations
donc je pense que après les Jeux
les fédérations attention vous allez
avoir des licenciés alors est-ce que il
faudra gagner beaucoup de médailles pour
pour ces Jeux olympiques de 2024 et 33
médailles qui ont été remportés à Tokyo
lors des derniers JO est-ce qu'il faudra
faire mieux s'il faudra gagner forcément
pour attirer encore plus de licenciés et
promouvoir le sport en français Victor
je pense qu'il y a un double jeu il y a
évidemment la tête de 50 médailles en
2024 je pense qu'il y a vraiment ce
double enjeu et à l'enjeu vraiment
sportif là pour le coup qui repose sur
les athlètes et puis plus largement les
fédérations évidemment l'objectif de
résultat on va dire donc si c'était 33
médailles la dernière fois oui le
chiffre de 50 paraît être certainement
un objectif réalisable maintenant il y
aura aussi je pense une dimension un peu
plus sociétale qui sera aussi énormément
importante voilà à Paris 2024 veut être
un exemple notamment pour les futurs
organisateurs de jeux etc d'un point de
vue voilà vraiment citoyen donc je pense
que voilà il y a ces deux dimensions là
il faut que les athlètes français
gagnent beaucoup de médailles
voilà le pouvoir de la France mais il y
a aussi cet enjeu à côté un look il
faudra gagner en 2024
que pour de nos vies envies à des
enfants se mettre à l'équitation ce sera
aussi la manière dont ça va être
véhiculé et les images
les
images et surtout que les réseaux
sociaux ça va super vite donc ça ça va
être super important pour donner envie
aux jeunes de se mettre à l'équitation
ça serait une belle récompense de voir
des petits Victor l'évêque Anouk quand
tout à l'avenir peut-être qui vont faire
ce que vous faites une récompense ouais
bien sûr après nous on est quand même
une fédération gâtée puisque on est
quand même la troisième fédération en
termes de licencié en France parce qu'on
peut faire plus bien sûr après je suis
pas à la tête de la fédération mais
j'imagine que ouais il y a toujours
cette volonté de faire plus d'autant
plus que voilà aujourd'hui je pense que
l'équitation a plein de belles valeurs à
faire valoir c'est pas le seul mais l'un
des seuls sports mixtes aux Jeux
Olympiques voilà il y a plein d'autres
choses le côté nature contact avec
l'animal ce qui rend ce sport si unique
donc oui j'espère que les jeux se rend
formidables etc
vous pouvez développer peut-être avec
une performance le Para tennis de table
tout est possible je
Florian
c'est ce qu'on nous raconte toute la
journée et du coup ça doit être
performant alors on va terminer par un
quiz sur
les deux Paris 2024 alors on va voir si
vous êtes fort on va faire peut-être
deux équipes on va faire une équipe
peut-être avec Anouk et Victor la team
équitation et de l'autre côté un petit
duo entre vous Lucie et Florian alors on
va regarder on va je vais vous poser des
questions et ensuite faudra répondre je
vais noter à chaque fois et on va voir
qui qui gagne à la fin alors première
question qui est le président du comité
d'organisation des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 vous pouvez écrire du coup
sur
sur vos petites tablettes oui il faut
répondre assez rapidement mais bon
[Musique]
je crois qu'il va avoir déjà le premier
point pour la team équitation Tony
estanguay on va regarder la réponse tout
de suite
voilà Tony estanguay qui est l'ancien
champion olympique de canoë qui est
président du comité d'organisation des
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 on va
passer à la deuxième donc un point pour
vous un la team équitation on va passer
à la deuxième question il y aura combien
d'épreuves aux JO de 2024 combien
d'épreuves alors je prendrai la personne
qui la plus proche
[Musique]
l'épreuve de sport des preuves
alors on va voir tout de suite la
réponse
329 épreuves donc
au final Florian vous êtes devant
Florian vous êtes vous êtes le plus
proche donc 329 épreuves en France enfin
dans tous les jeux Olympiques en 2004
voilà alors troisième question combien
il y aura des preuves dans les Yvelines
dans les Yvelines seulement dans les
Yvelines
des preuves ou de des preuves dans les
Yvelines des preuves pas de sport des
preuves
je vous laisse
20 pour Victor et à nous et 16 alors on
va voir la réponse
32 épreuves dans les Yvelines
bravo Victor deuxième point bah oui bien
sûr bravo parce que je vois qu'elle
souffle beaucoup de réponses depuis tout
à l'heure
le score alors on va passer à la
quatrième question combien de sites
ivinois vont accueillir les épreuves
paralympiques en 2024 combien de sites
yvelinois vont accueillir les épreuves
paralympiques en 2024
c'est pour Lucie normalement 4 5 et il y
aura la réponse
deux sites dans les Yvelines le vélo
Drôme de 50 ans en Yvelines et le
château de Versailles donc du coup la
colline il y aura pas forcément toutes
les épreuves c'est pour ça il y aura pas
des épreuves il y aura pas par exemple
du VTT sur la colline d'Élancourt pour
les épreuves par
contre
alors on va on va mettre je sais plus
combien vous allez c'était Florian c'est
quand même alors de partout on va passer
à la cinquième question comment
s'appelle les mascottes de l'épreuve des
JO de 2024
[Musique]
normalement tout le monde les connaît
effectivement on va regarder la réponse
friche pour les deux
donc un point chacun on va passer à la
6e question pour les JO de 2024 quelles
sont les quatre disciplines
additionnelles
attention
quels sont les quatre disciplines
additionnelles pour les JO de 2024
Florian je pensais à un mais
c'est un peu compliqué Florian vous avez
attention c'est pas parfait mais
alors le marathon vous avez mis le skate
le break et le surf et pour vous du coup
break skate alors on va voir la réponse
alors il y a le surf l'escalade le
breakdance et le skateboard et le
breakdance ce sera une grande première
pour le coup donc un point de plus pour
la team équitation attention 4 3 pour la
team équitation on va passer maintenant
à la question 7 avant 2024 combien de
fois la France a accueilli les Jeux
olympiques d'été
une fois pour Victor et deux fois pour
Florian
d'accord alors on va regarder tout de
suite la réponse et c'était deux fois
c'était tente 1900 et en 1900 à 24
seules Londres et bientôt le Los Angeles
en 2028 font aussi bien donc un point
chacun 5 4 on passe à la question 8
alors on va regarder la question dans un
instant
Jo 2024 quand Paris a-t-elle été désigné
ville haute en 2014
pour vous Victor et à nous
2016 pour vous Florian et Lucie on va
regarder la réponse tout de suite
en septembre 2017 à nous qui avait la
bonne réponse mais Victor ne l'a pas
écouté apparemment et bien ça se termine
par une égalité entre les deux équipes
bravo aux équipes du coup vous avez
quasiment bon quasiment chaque fois en
tout cas vous étiez pas très loin pas
très loin on va bien alors c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission on va terminer
ceci en parlait sport spécial Jeux
Olympiques par une citation de Pierre de
Coubertin le père fondateur des Jeux
Olympiques modernes le plus important au
jeu olympiques ce n'est pas de gagner
mais de participer car l'important dans
la vie ce n'est point le triomphe mais
le combat ce n'est pas à d'avoir vaincu
mais de s'être bien battu je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
TV 78
[Musique]